hello everyone good morning good
afternoon and good evening from
whichever part you are joining in from
and my name is Ovid I'm the host for
today's session if you are able to hear
me go ahead and give me a hi hello on
the chat window so that we can get to
know that you are able to hear us
wonderful thank you so much for your
responses people are some of the ground
rules of the session is like everyone
will be on mute to avoid the background
noise so you have any question you will
be utilizing the chat option okay so
first thing let me introduce you to our
speaker Luciana police she's one among
the people who has more than 10 years of
experience in Lean Six Sigma tools
she's the consultant and the founder of
be storming training and consulting
Quality Engineer in certified by
American Society of quality she has
participated in an examination and on
the team excellence award for it so she
is the speaker author of American
Society of quality she has more credits
than I can talk about without any
further ado let me go ahead and unmute
Luciana before that I would like to keep
you posted that of 45 minutes of the
first session of the session will will
reserve for Luciana to give her lecture
last 10 to 15 minutes who will keep it
for the question-and-answer so if you
have any questions please reserve it for
for the last section of the session so
without any further ado I'll go ahead
and unmute Luciana a Luciana
thanks for being alright all yours
I'll go ahead unmute we can start it for
now
[Music]
[Music]
okay start with agenda for today we're
going to see the music sing definition
we're going to see the benefits of
applying within your organization we're
going to see the toolkit all the things
that we can do directly after this we'll
use sessions that you can go back to
your work and start implementing means
in Sigma right now we're going to learn
what is the demand methodology and with
we are features we are examples of
companies that are already implementing
it and we're going to check the system I
mean summary okay so let's just get
started with the presentation so let's
review what is the definition for en Six
Sigma so in recent years there were two
methods that are open doing
manufacturing processes have come to the
front that are basically and Six Sigma
they were used to serve two different
types of witness problems in the past
back today lean and Six Sigma are
integrated into one methodology and
toolset for solving any process roll
them in any type of organization from
fortune 500 companies just now we're at
business to nonprofit institutions
believe me that this is something is
real I've been using it in any kind of
company there is more from just one
person to big companies like coca-cola
so 16-month
the quality of manufacturing outputs by
using statistical tools to minimize the
variations on the other hand lean
manufacturing is a production whether
that eliminates waste thereby increasing
the endpoint value for the customers
so both matters have been used
successfully by large corporations in
the United States in India and in Japan
in any part of so the real truth is that
at the very beginning lean and Six Sigma
both started in the manufacturing sites
Six Sigma is a philosophy of process
management developed by Motorola in the
80s that uses statistical methods to
minimize errors over the long term
manufacturing processes tend to deviate
from the standard so Six Sigma is
helping to reduce that deviation in the
case of 16 the case of aluminium Fortran
sorry
it began in Japanese manufacturing after
World War 2 crisis eg tesora and Daiichi
oh no from Toyota the common foreign
company went to visit American plants
because they were in crisis so they
organized their learnings in a new
system called did for just-in-time which
later was called as GPS or Toyota
Production system but that system was
was a bit laid behind after like in the
90s James one African American guy wrote
a book about his new methodology to be
used to implement across the world on
norm only manufacturing and he call it
lean manufacturing it basic usefulness
is in providing the tool to identify the
laminate waste to put the manufacturing
process so this is how Six Sigma started
and lean when pattern started so what is
Lean Six Sigma together today Lean Six
Sigma is a systemic approach to
improving the way people do process
improvement
mythology that is involved that allows
them to systematically enhance your
process business I really in business
for two reasons right
one is to satisfy the customer and the
other one is to make money so there
always is in mind you have a systemic
approach to improve improve processes
and to satisfy the customer today what
we're going to see is how this systemic
approach works and of course we are
going to see what are the benefits so
let's move to the next line one of the
benefits is increase employee
involvement increasing parental
involvement is one of the big benefits
of name Six Sigma through their
participation numbers enrollment teams
designed to help the improving processes
and increase value for their own
customers so people gets really really
involved because they actually can see
how they can help their company to grow
what they are doing to grow the
processes and to improve customer
satisfaction so by involving employees
in implementation of this program they
gain a greater appreciation for the
impact of your what they do on bottom
line business results as well as an
appreciation for how the work of our
employees and departments also
contribute to success so this is one of
the key benefits the second benefit is
that you have reduced cost one of the
primary the spired benefits is a
reduction in cost associated with
improvements to process to require less
time to with defects or errors that can
result in work by examining the various
steps involving a process understanding
what customers value and the taking
steps are imminent unnecessary steps you
can also increase value value for the
customer but also you will be reducing
your cost so you can see you can you can
say like from 20 to 50 percent of your
cost
that's great thing but as I said you are
not only going to involve your employees
and
just cost but also you will be
increasing customer satisfaction
so Lean Six Sigma methodology was a
strong focus on customer needs and they
leave any high value to them so you will
not only focus on the process but also
you will know you will also focus on how
the customer is going to receive your
product on your service and of course
ultimately increase not to my
satisfaction will need to repeat
business increase positive word-of-mouth
and with that assessment orientation you
will also increase sales and of course
overall business census so what is that
customer wants customer wants everything
right we always see if you are if you
always see customers within your
business you may be the owner of the
business you may be just one of the
employees that customers want everything
so in six sigma indian is a systemic
process to continually improve what they
want which is quality cost and delivery
time whatever the phone or whatever the
service all customers are looking for
this 3x faster that would be I will use
cycle time so that they can get the
order much faster they want better
performance of course better quality and
what's more they want cheaper or less so
in Six Sigma will help you known these
matters so let me show you now this is
the demand methodology this is the
famous in my toolkit that is similar to
the one used just for 16 Lean Six Sigma
projects comprise aspects of Lee's voice
elimination and the 16 my focus on
reducing defects based on these damag
methodology then in my toolkit of mean
Six Sigma comprise all the name and
safety modules
Demark is the project loss every six in
my effort and represents define measure
analyze improve and control that will be
defining the problem understanding how
to measure the effect of the project so
you can see how you are where you want
to be first step is analyzing the
process through experimentation then the
fourth one once you know one is that you
want to improve just have to go on and
prove the process based on the solutions
and put in controls at the end in place
to maintain the improvement
so where is lean this denial process
lean is basically on there I am singing
updating - it's there it's basically
part of the improve under control as you
will see later on moving to the next
slide you will see a chart with that in
my tools this is the table shows some of
the 16 modules of course it's not
imperative to use every tool on every
project but here you can see a wide
range of tools that you can that you can
use in each of the steps again you know
you can use some of the tools in values
of the steps for example you can use for
example depth brainstorming which is a
very common tool in the measure measure
space you can use it in their analyze
phase or you can use it in improve it
it's all up to you the tools are for you
to use whenever you want them you just
need to learn which tool is the best for
each each part of the process that we
need to deliver
we have the lean tools as you can see on
the slide lean tools have a lot of
another one side five base objectives
engines to see perfection
I love customers to pull great flow
identify the value stream and ending
waste and finally standardized Amazon
eyes customer value this is their well
known house of quality of the house of
Toyota Production system with the roof
of the house is Kevin the Japanese word
that stands for continuous improvement
so what we're going to see today is
where are we going to use all these
tools like they want with fall with TPM
fibers or visual factory continuing than
in Maya mythology well before
the man Authority just let me tell you
one last thing which is the training the
training for Nasik Sigma is provided
through the bail based training system
which is very similar to the judo one so
they have been depending on the amount
and complexity of the tools but that
every employee is trained personnel are
designated as white bells yellow bells
ringing bells weapons and even master
glasses again very similar to children
black belts tend to be brushed leaders
white green ones usually are protecting
members and this is all the steps that
we're going to see today let's get
started with it define this is the first
step of the denying afford so one of the
outputs for a defined base you have to
define the port on the service you have
to identify your customers you have to
define the process and you have to
understand the customer requirements so
this is a phrase I like very much which
is which was said by Joseph Juran one of
the main rules of quantity which says
unemployment takes place
project-by-project and in no other way
so this is the way that 16 I mean start
getting together I mean a project so the
first thing that you have to do to start
news in the Romanian astrology is having
a project to work on you have to look at
your processes and see what's going
wrong when where our customers from
blaming or where your employees
complaining that they have to work too
hard or they have to walk too fast
and it's not okay for them so when you
have some kind of issues or where you're
having a lot of cost that you would like
to reduce whether you may have a product
so once you have the plan your project
then
except that I would recommend to do is
to use and type of diagram let's type of
diagram is useful to see the big picture
and find whether it ends where it ends
process and where it starts so now we
are getting getting closer to what a
manufacturing company is right so let's
see what is the process of a bottling
company for example let's type of China
S stands for suppliers input process
output and customers so the first thing
that you need to do with your process is
to understand it how you understand it
the first name is to define which are
your suppliers you need to see that
every tasks that you do have something
that is that starts before and something
that starts after you finish your
process so the best thing that each of
your employees need to know how their
processes are connected to other tasks
of the other people in the company so we
have our process for both length and the
process for both let have suppliers it
may be both name company or it may be
including those those the supplier in
the place provide inputs those inputs
are worthless juice states that will
enable me to bottle the juice in the
bottom then once I finish the process
for bottling I have the output which is
the juice button and the customer which
is the distributor which is going to
distribute my juice or new employees
than me drinking so what about if the
process itself or bottling well you just
have to write all the tasks that are
related to your process in my case would
be first clean the bottles that have
been received from the supplier for hot
juice into the bottles
cross the bottles invert them so that
the Jews get to them
so all the part of the bottle then you
have to cool it down then you have to
label it and then you like it once you
finish all the steps you are ready to
have the juice bottles and distributed
okay so this is the first step so then
you know exactly where to start now
now then you know what comes after and
what comes before your process you have
to want have big difference which is
going to doing it tortured the
four-track is a pictorial representation
of the sequence of steps in the process
it's very similar to what we have
already done but is more detail so in
this process Walter I have included also
not only the steps but also they're
responsible for each of them which is
operations purchases and reception in
this case so the floater the basic
usefulness of the flow chart is that you
develop a common understanding of the
process what will when where and how
this way you also identifying
opportunities so you have you can this
way you can see if you if there are
problem areas or mean efficiencies or if
you're in you have redundancy if you cut
recycling if there are gaps between the
edges and the idea so filters are very
useful some for you to see what's going
on your process and it also will help
you to standardize how work is done
float is also very useful to a trainee
employees also to document the process
so this is one of them very very first
tools that you need to use as a green
belt or black belt so now that you have
defined your process and you have
defined what is that you are going to
have a son as an output of your process
you have to measure how it works that's
the second step of their mind which is
the measure phase the measure of fair
allows you to understand their before
percent conditional process before you
attempt to identify improvements because
the measure phase is based upon body
data it eliminates guesswork about how
well your process is working because you
know sometimes you say yeah my process
is working well that can you actually
say that it's working well do you know
you know what is the profitability of
the business do you know the cost that
you're having you know the cycle time
well if you don't know that you're not
sure if it's actually going well I mean
it's going quite well so well that you
need to do is try to define which is the
process output measures that you want to
have what is that you want to measure
you have to have a performance
measurement and you have to identify the
gaps with the idea of process
measurement this is another very nice
phrase that I like to use that is if you
don't measure work processes or you
can't possibly manage them and that was
that but by Bill Hewlett and this is
very right as I said before if you
cannot measure what you're doing it's
very very difficult that you can manage
it because the only way to show your
employees that something is going wrong
that people is complaining that the
manufacturing process is very slow or is
very cost effective or it's not
perspective then if you cannot tell them
the truth you cannot turn the numbers
well you can actually make them change
anything about it so the first thing is
that you have your process flow chart
and start measuring how it's working so
one of the measurement tools that I can
use is to actually go on count or
measure what you're doing so you have
your process flow chart and then you
first need to request materials or you
have to request water suppliers
so measure how much time you spend
requesting words to your fires so let's
say you spend an hour okay but then the
next step is selecting your supplier
how much time do you spend until you
actually select the supplier factor
sometimes it takes like for example
three days or a week or two weeks you
know so this is a very important phase
of your and my own methodology you
actually need to know all the time that
you're spending not only by doing
something but on but also the time that
you're spending doing nothing like
waiting waiting for someone just like
suppliers waiting from from the supplier
to get you the supplies waiting for
getting their stuff actually on the
manufacturing plant so first to measure
everything we can about your process
once you have measured how your process
is going then you can analyze or move to
the next step where you can see why
you're not getting the results you want
why is it that I'm getting my supplies
for both we mined for bottling my juice
in two weeks five one in two days well
that's one we have to analyze we
basically in the analyze phase what
we're going to do is understand why
we're going to have these gaps so the
first tool that we can use to analyze if
the brainstorming the one that I
mentioned before just a technique for
generating a high volume of ideas on any
topic so you can use this to to
stimulate creativity within your team to
encourage any participant to lead on
another idea you get all the team
members involved because the
brainstorming session basically what you
do is harvest facilitator asking for
team members to look for new ideas you
just have to show your problem on a
chart on a screen and
then team members need to tell what what
they think it's the following about them
okay
brainstorming is a very important tool
it's very simple but it can be
encouraged be used together with other
tools like the fishbone diagram which is
the next to the fish were doing well mr.
brainstorming tuned is fine to identify
possible causes of the problem it's also
not known as a cause and effect diagram
or I'm using my diagram so what you can
do is just as you can see on the right
just show on the screen what is the
problem and start looking for the
different causes the different root
causes okay so what we do on the
official diagram you can just set like
signs or categories that are commonly
used or you can use your own then the
ones that are commonly used are what is
called the 6/10 which is machinery
methods material people environment and
measurement so as you can see on the
next slide a nice example I have of how
you can use that page one diagram to
analyze the causes of your problems for
example in this case we have non buying
time so why you may be having a long
line time because of your methods if you
go to the methods fine because you're
trimming from first vertex lumber
another option substitution takes long
let's say this is a clinic that you are
looking for buying things doctor is too
busy to pick up the phone okay let's go
to the person fine
maybe people is busy retrieving because
it's not a minute immediately available
for pronouncement many people is young
inexperienced so
this is some some parts that may be
affecting what is going on your process
so what's good about the Fishman hammer
is that you'll see in just one slide a
lot of root causes you just have to keep
asking why which is another tool that's
my wife
keep asking why something is going wrong
so why is that that we have problems
with the methods again why because we're
trimming from the first floor to a
climber why we trim from first floor
take longer then you keep answering why
until you get to the pipe and then you
are going to get the right answer what
you're going to - together with this
it's a lot of less than before
a lot of resources that you have to
analyze then experienced team which will
meet people from different from
different sectors in the company from
different areas even you can include
suppliers and customers they all can
vote and see which is the real root
cause for the problem another tool that
you can use to analyze well the
information that you have is the Pareto
charts the Pareto chart is very well
used if you have real data you know for
example waiting time or if you have
information about how much how much
because we're having well the Pareto
chart it's a form of bar chart that
helps to identify produce by displaying
them in an ascending order of frequency
or size so the Pareto principle is
founded on the observation that many
instances just a large percentage of
Burnham's are lost by only a small
percentage of the total contributing
factors so that if here you know you
will have like six or seven categories
of problems that if you just focused on
the first one which is going to have the
80% the Berlin
you will normally be solving one of the
process okay so just be solved one of
the closest and you will be resolving
80% of the problems difference principle
was established by with Philip original
in nineteen and he really studied that
it was an empty 20 room and it's applied
to any kind of industry we just have to
check your data and see where you get
the 80% of your problems so now you have
you have built your visual diagram you
had a little kasi
but then you have analyzed your process
and you have big data then you've got
your career chart to try to prioritize
which are there the courses that you got
and then you gave that one of the
constant things are the most important
about it so how you solve it you need to
work on the improved face and improve
face you will innovate look for
solutions and test them test them into
as a pilot area that's the most common
way of doing it and if in that kind of
area it works then you can implement the
solution across the company
so here in the blue face as I said
before is where we're going to start
using the very demeaning tools so this
the some tools are going to help you
basically to reduce the eight waste that
every company can have the anyways are
non value-adding activities which is in
here for the Dozen free by affordable or
the customer minutes that needs to be
eliminated or reduced those eight ways
that you have the acronym for downtime
are defects or production waiting
one-by-one and assessing transport
change from inventory motion waste and
utilized skills so bling tools will help
you eliminating all these aid waste and
the first one I always recommend to
struggle with when you have a when you
want to implement that in my methodology
within the plant if the fibrous which is
to organize the work place using the
fibers the fibers inside and Japanese
methodology that has five steps that
will help you organize where the work in
a way that it's easier to see the defect
and it is it work
it's easy also to to visualize what's
going well what's one run and easy for
anyone to see not only for experienced
people or of a rigorous or immune
employees and also for customers so what
is 5s about the first type of 5s is sort
with two separate needed tools materials
and instructions from those that are not
needed you have to remove everything
that is not in it from the work area so
once you have split what do you need
from what you don't you need to so we'll
watch you on turning it you have to sort
and organize all tools equipment files
data a material and resources for quick
easy location and use you have to label
all the locations on the tools and the
equipment so that everyone can see it
and find in less than 30 seconds less
than 30 seconds if you are spending more
not to find any tool when you're having
a problem and you may be looking forward
to implement progress so once you have
stored on your pressure of material your
whatever you brought out finished
products equipment or any kind of
material then you need to set a new
level of cleanliness in the shine step
you have to clean and remove all trash
buoys and dirt what happens mostly in in
a manufacturing environment
is that quiz on dirt are a way of hiring
difference so as soon as possible that
you can remove any grease any dirt any
trash then you will be able to what's
going on what's going well so if there's
a machine that is not working properly
if it's clean you will see exactly when
you are getting a flow of water that
shouldn't be there the flow of oil
grease that shouldn't be there
cleanliness provides a safe work area
and makes potential problems miss so you
will be able to learn to allow me to see
document links before they lose parts
Winson rods whose paper or materials
whatever the first step for the 5s is to
standardize which we're going to see
lenient later on as well in and amaya in
then the control phase okay
but in one also having a grain the
fibers so it's analyzed with me to
systematically do that one second and
third step from 5x so you have to
establish schedules for cleaning in you
have to define standards for each of the
processes and the five part that the
five step is to sustaining the only way
that Lean Six Sigma can work if it's
been sustained it you have to make me
and Six Sigma the same way as 5s as part
of your culture you have to build an
organization of commitment so that the
two is sustained through time let me
tell you one more thing
Toyota Honda a very great friend of
fibers so here I know now will tell you
that 25 to 30 percent for quality
defects are directly related to order
and cleanliness in the work so that's
really true now what's more is on this
is also 5s
a great contributor to to employee
satisfaction and workplace because they
feel more comfortable with when they are
working so moving to the next tool as
you can see this is some pictures of my
desk where you can see some tools very
well organized you have these are all
pictures of real real examples of
factories where employees have been
working on 5s trying to order an answer
the parts there the materials for the
words the tools so this helps them much
better to improve the processes they do
improve how they work they are much
faster and they just know when they need
something
the next picture we also show you how
you can not only have fines from there
on the tools but also you can have signs
from the floor chart showing where you
should put any kind of material so that
you don't get them lost these another
good example when you can have you can
have places to put on there all the
materials that you need but as much as
possible that you can see one that's
much better
you may use labels that you also can use
transparent parts you know that drawers
transparent drawers so that you can see
everything that is inside and you can
figure out incident where you have to
change it or where you have to buy more
stuff
this is we it were very to another so
that is very very important
means 16 monkeys a visual factory okay
this is the same picture further the
droid I would just saw remember this one
okay
go back do you remember this one okay
this one's funded on the door you will
see that's fine which is red or green
showing where you need to change why you
need to change either the tools or any
more material so visual factor is a big
part of music cinema you need visual
signs to help you have real-time
dashboards real-time things I will tell
you what to do and when to do it and
this helps a lot team leaders on the
factory floor
you can see that - Yura is much more
effective than General Motors that team
leaders and 90% of the time on the front
because they have all the information
they need right in they don't have it on
the computer they just have it on the
floor and that's that's a very good
thing about visual factoring here you
have another example this is a box I
used to have glue for a half factory and
you know they're saying please just cut
cap they're the boss so that they can
see find how much glue they have and
it's easier for them to identify when
they need to buy more another good tool
for an in Six Sigma 2 1 when this waste
is Pocoyo Guruji's mystic proofing
devices which is the practice of
Australian for serie defect to prevent
errors
it applies to any process where
repetitive steps of pure which could be
skipped for format of order or not
conducted correctly mystic proofing
ensures that tasks can only be done the
right way you can use right you can use
find whatever you need so that you can
show right away what's going right and
what's wrong
I also use very much example of the
Excel when you are writing something
that is not correct when you are
supposed to write a date and writing
some
writing letters then you will receive a
message on the excel file the same in
you know any earpiece instance like SOP
you get a message showing hey this is
not what you should be doing
so before you continue working on that
we already see what's going on an hour
into that it's very much used its mad
which is stands for a single minute
exchange of time and refers to the time
it should take to set up a machine to
produced apart it's very very common as
you can see there are some examples of
companies that need to do fasting jurors
well men is a very good tool to reduce
the time of death change overs in
automatic plans there are numerous
instances where it would take like three
or four hours to do that so with the use
of this maintenance the set-up time
would be reduced to minutes for example
the other day I went through to your
fund and really you were having like a
new car every 110 seconds right and it
was any kind of car with any quarter it
wasn't like shameful act cars
no it wasn't great car 110 minutes later
you would have a black car around 10
minutes later you would have like a band
now it's it was wonderful so that is
basically one of the things that are
great about Smith another tool
Toa preventive maintenance which is to
try the operators to contribute to
keeping the equipment in good condition
that's another great tool that you can
use for given Sigma so how much time you
lose when you need to repair machine
well you can't create a flow if you
start if you just spend one or seven
minutes you know every day before using
it until minutes to clean it after but
you will never have small machines going
down instead of just spending three
hours every to it to spend five minutes
every day and you will work much better
and you will know how it works if your
operators know how the machines work
they will be much better prepared to fix
it faster and to make it work much
better and our tool is the Kanban Kanban
is a great tool which is also very
visual and if it's not as it says like a
feminine system but rather a production
control system and if not automated is
in very very simple tune it's just
currents forcing months being pilots
whatever you need to visualize how
things are never if I'm use like this
Christ and then showing them that's
right because postage to show how things
are working on their next line we're
going to see that there are pilots you
can have different colors like green if
something is already processed and read
back or you can use red if something
needs to be fixed or something needs to
be arranged
well you can use as I said you can use
parts they only knew how much materials
you need for any product you can have
parts to tell you that broke right very
you need a lot of imagination to be able
to you as well is
grunts and you can use it in any process
it's very much like the waiter when they
then get your order on the restaurant
but that would be like left on one card
if you got it if you got it to it to the
chef
so they want this all these tools were
part of that front face so now you have
defined your process you measure how it
should work
you have analyzed why is not working
that well then you have improve it and
now it's time for control me to monitor
what you have been working on to make
sure it is sustained through time so one
of the tools I will use a lot for
controlling is the control chart which
is an advanced form of branch art which
displays how stable is a process and
what types of variation it is magic tool
as you can see this is nice well it's
nice if not very clean right but it's a
very good place where you can get all
information you need to form the line
and stuff just going to the computer you
just roll to there to the plant before
and say what are the metrics for
production for cost for quality security
for HR you can put whatever you need as
long as you can measure it and what I
recommend is that the measures are done
directly value operation thank each of
the employees draw in a very simple very
simple graph from their doing and what
which are the objectives so that you can
see if you're working or not in this
case for example you have an objective
of 103 and when you're having now you're
using paper and you want to have it for
me to 1.3%
but in this case they're having very
very bad numbers as you can see because
they're on top of the testing okay but
is it something
because the operator exactly one know
what is going wrong and which day it
went wrong and maybe they can figure out
if there's something to correct on that
particular day so as I said control is
part of monitoring and controlling but
you also need to try to have procedures
you need to standardize what you have
been doing the same thing that I
mentioned with 5s that the four step of
5s was standardizing when you have your
demand methodology in the control part
you also need to make sure it's
sustained so time and the only way to
sustain a change through time is using
standardized standard operating
procedures that will be manuals or that
would be things for their standardized
voice of cleaning ways of preparing a
package ways of solving a problem ways
of cleaning a certain tool or a certain
machine always to do a fasting one you
need to write it down
so in the case that you defined with
mean with as med you define a way to do
your your change your responses then we
need to write them one so that it helps
everyone to find the best way to perform
each operation okay what happen is that
if you have a small company well maybe
there's trans one person during one of
their tivities right maybe you are a
restaurant and you have some someone
that is cooking or you have a plant
where you are know where you are having
the front example of them what company
will need to find it the best way to
model every every juice so all must
understand the notion that variation
needs equal to difference
so if you have to be aspiration you will
reduce that effect levels and the only
way to reduce vary
mr. Hawks done the work but if everyone
doing things the same way and the same
way that is the best way the best way
that is this common of course you know
everything one has to do with quality
management they also have to go with
continuous improvement so you need to
focus on improving whatever you do
continue doing it every time so maybe
you want to find the best way to perform
one iteration but maybe the next day one
of the new employees realizes that there
is a better way well then you need to
update your process and shogen on
communicating so everyone else knows
exactly what is the best way so what is
good about is that work is to be
performed according to the standard but
this rule applies to everyone
sorry workers to supervisors to managers
to tell me boss whoever so everyone
needs to have a standard for what they
are doing every day
ok so this is the end let's so just in
summary of the Olympic stigma train one
that we have hot today
first you need to define the value in
terms of the customers then you need to
measure then you start value versus the
real value the first step you need to
analyze processes student protosses
the fourth step you need to improve by
reduce waste and leave then last step
would be to control and seek for
perfection that would be containing
improving in every time but always
trying and monitoring what you have
already and little like it like a siphon
you will never finish
once you finish performing then you have
to define new values or new projects to
work on so this is state on my end I
just would like to thank you very much
for listening to this session I would
like to
thank you very much and asked you if you
had any questions please feel free to
write your questions on there on the
questions part of Newark on your
dashboard please feel free we will have
like five to ten minutes of questions
thank you so much the siano for that I
know let me go from the top the first
question and us coming in from email if
there's a problem not identify on how to
identify that if there is any problem
which has not been identified and in
case in case if there is a possibility
to identify it how to do that question
let me repeat if what do you do if you
kind of find a problem so basically the
question are intrigue that if there is
any problem which is not being
identified in how to identify the
problem so maybe he is referring to the
recurring problem but we're in a root
cause has not been performed but needs
if if there is any certain tip or which
which can help them to identify the
problem right well the first thing I
would recommend to do is just check on
what are their customer and what is the
customer experience you know just check
if your customers are having any issues
and then start asking questions so if
let's say your customers are receiving
your first late okay so you're having a
lot of questions some of why you're not
getting the product on time so just try
to write on the customers and that had a
claim on that write them down and start
asking why it's happening
then you in order to that press you get
information for your customers and then
you have a brainstorming session with
your team and then start checking why
what could be the reasons for that
happen
maybe the that way they can realize
their saponin whether with the materials
maybe they can't find out there's a
problem with the the communication with
the customer maybe they're surprised
with the communication with the supplier
okay once you start getting to know more
about the problem you will be able to
get a project on which exactly what is
that you have to focus on there's a
problem with the supplier maybe then you
can start approaching on how improving
the time you get you know material from
the supplier so then you can get your
faster and get it faster to your
customers I hope that is answering the
question great thanks and when we are
talking about the customer this is this
is one of the questions from what so ok
can you just talk about the internal
customers for example financial
department or logistics great yeah well
that's a great question about their
having an internal and external customer
because that's totally true Lean Six
Sigma focuses on both customers both
external customers we would be who
actually buys the product and uses it or
you can be an internal customer which
could be accountants to be logistics as
you said it could be any any other kind
of starting in your process that's why I
suggested at the very beginning that you
need to do this type of diagram the size
of diagram will help you identify we
turn there we turn the customers of your
process it would be an internal customer
maybe once you finish your task
maybe you finished producing your your
product then you need to send it to
someone in accounting or maybe you need
to prepare a report for them to tell
them how how we have us
rate which were the cost of your product
well you need to work you need to know
exactly what is that your customer wants
they want as I said before you want the
documentation faster they want another
kind of documentation that maybe they
needed through an email maybe they need
them to voicemail maybe they need and so
what's up you know you can use any tool
to to get communicated with them but you
need to ask them first what is that one
okay great thank you thanks for that and
can you comment on which tool works
better on a transactional process versus
the flow factory floor processes well
the tool you don't have a better tool it
depends on what you need to fix so first
what I would recommend is to check the
graphs for their lean tools and for the
Six Sigma tools where you can see in
which stage you are and what is the best
tool for each of the stages so we
depends vertical you need to check if
you are trying to look for improving
something or you're trying to look for
for more information you know you're in
the measure of faith and you need to
look for for date time or maybe you need
to to control your process much better
you need to check which is more their
best offer for the stage that you want
maybe you can send an email to me with
example and I can and I guess I'll be
much better on that so I can't give you
that the better tool they're there right
to offer for that for that situation God
that God thank you
and one of the interesting question
coming from Steven is how could we apply
Lean Six Sigma and service production
well
question naphthalene Sigma can be used
in any kind of industry not only
manufacturing but also in services for
example I'm using 5s very much in stores
you know sometimes tours have a lot of
products that are that cannot be sold
because they are broken or they are out
of fashion or maybe they are full of
dust you know they are not clean and 5s
the great tools will help you ensure
that the place where you have all their
on their produce that you need to sell
are clean and in good condition and then
of course you can't find it faster
because once you have a customer is
looking for something they need to buy
they don't want to win like 30 minutes
so that you can find them so 5s it's
like great tool but of course is not the
only one for example you can use the
sidewalk for forgetting the service
process as I was as I was saying for
example if you are going to to a
restaurant that is a service process
mixed with a manufacturing one right but
the waiter and getting your order but
it's like a service process and you can
draw this type of the same way for
example there you are the supplier is
the person that that gets the food and
they input it it's the fourth the
process is called preparing the order
with with the food for the customer then
the output would be the table serve and
the customer would be done so you can
use any of these tools in any kind of
environment all right great
thank you and the next question is how
Lean Six Sigma can be applied in non
manufacturing company what's your
thoughts on non manufacturing company or
about Lean Six Sigma implementation well
it's very similar to two there the
previous question yes I really I'm
really using music Sigma in in other non
manufacturing environments to tell you
the truth the I'm implementing 16 ma
music Sigma in coca-cola and I'm
implementing it in every part of it I'm
implementing it in the bahtman part and
implementing it in the quality lab also
in the administrative sectors for
accountants in the kitchen on the
security part when you get into the
plant you need to get you know the less
security done my place were there the
employees now have learned so Lean Six
Sigma can be used anywhere just have to
try to find the best tools that you can
use for it for each of the steps as I
said
Pyrus is one of the first ones that you
can use in any of them but then you can
you can use the sidewalk you can use
control charts to analyze for your your
people is doing it can be in for example
in accounting you can use the control
charts to see how many mistakes you're
making you can see how many late entries
you're having I used it
yes it seemed also very much in EXO mori
that's am you know a very very
well-known multinational company for oil
industry and I was using it in there in
the accounting side you know purchases
sales everyone was using 16 much improve
their processes as well because in
accounting wouldn't have the right
documentation on time
maybe the manufacturing part wouldn't
have the supplies on time so everything
here should be connected okay great
thank you are Luciana and one more last
question and that's coming on the exam
how long does it takes to get certified
on main Six Sigma and the participant
original question how difficult is to
get certified so with with this answer
we'll wrap up the session and also I do
apologize participant we will not be
able to answer all the questions however
I will be sending out the details of
this session you know like someone
questioned on recordings we will be
sharing the recordings you can revert to
my email on your questions I'll get it
answered by Luciana on on the same so
the final question for you will be on
exam how long does it takes to get
certified on being Six Sigma and how
difficult it is well actually there is
now just one question or one I'm so
sorry for that question the answer is
that it depends it depends on you mean
Six Sigma have a lot of tools and then
what I would recommend is to start with
a certification for green belt so that
you have you get to know the main tools
there how much it will take well it
depends on the kind of course you have
for example you have the simply neural
crest where you can take it on your own
pace so you can take as much as you need
to to do it it's it's all active how
fast you get to know the tools and what
I would recommend you to practice it
because it's not just important to to
get a certification but also to be able
to apply faster and I mean in a good
fashion so it's not difficult it's
really easy I find said in in the whole
session that was are not difficult to
use the tools are simple the tools are
very very good
any kind of employees is not running for
management but it's also for operators
or for clerical people our friend mr. t
or whoever
so I would really recommend that you
start working that you can start slow
just take your have you take your your
time to do it that is not difficult you
won't see that once you start learning
about it you will love it and you
wouldn't want to learn much more so that
you can get to them master black belt so
I wish you a lot of success on that
thanks thanks for that Louisiana and
they stated everyone the recording of
this session will be shared however the
presentation I'm afraid we will not be
able to share the PDF files as this is
developed for the framing purpose only
however I will share the recording links
from each one of you and once again
let's thank you Siana her on her
expertise you know considering the the
schedule and respecting the time and the
value of it we'll conclude by now and I
will be sharing the recordings tomorrow
or to each and every one of you you have
any question do not hesitate to bring
the question to me I will forward it to
Luciana and get it answered or else I
will create a link on our community you
can you can post your queries there
we're in our Luciana we'll be able to
quell answer that questions as well so I
I totally enjoyed the the session
Luciana thank you once again for your
expertise and your knowledge on our
green our Lean Six Sigma and with this
or we we will go ahead and close the
session and the recordings will be sent
tomorrow thank you once again everyone
joining the session and have a good day
take care bye
you